madame la Présidente et chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre lors de sa
réélection en avril 2022 face au
rassemblement national le président
Macron avait déclaré ce vote m'oblige
pour les années à venir depuis cet
engagement n'a trouvé d'écho ni dans la
politique menée ni dans la pratique du
pouvoir les élections législatives
avaient pourtant confirmé la nécessité
pour le camp présidentiel privé de
majorité absolue de gouverner autrement
et de rééquilibrer les pouvoirs le
mandat de Madame borne s'est au
comptaire inscrit dans la continuité de
pratiqu brutal avec pour pratique
nouvelle 23 493 et s'il fallait
attribuer une palme elle serait décernée
au 493 qui s'est abattu sur la réforme
des retraites malgré l'opposition de 80
% des Français et de la majorité de
l'hémicycle violence institutionnelle et
renimement des engagements tel est le
résumé de ce but de quinena qui s'est
achevé en donnant à l'extrême droite une
victoire idéologique majeure en céd dans
toute honte bu au fantasme avec
l'adoption d'un texte sur l'immigration
contraire à la loi fondamentale en
créant un appel d' au racisme tout en
fragilisant notre État de droit certes
plus d'une trentaine de mesures ont été
censurées par le Conseil constitutionnel
mais l'irréparable a déjà été commis
laissant derrière son passage blessure
et conséquences monsieur le nouveau
Premier ministre vous êtes non seulement
comptable de ce triste bilan mais vous
avez été désigné comme commissaire
politique par le Président de la
République pour poursuivre l'œuvre
entamée le 16 janvier dernier il vous a
rappelé que le détenteur suprême du
pouvoir exécutif c'est
lui vous venez de le confirmer avec
votre gouvernement mondain de l'entre
soi vous servirez sa politique au
service des riches une politique qui
creuse toujours davantage les inégalités
avec fierté dites-vous sans jamais
douter avec arrogance c'est cette
feuille de route qui vous a été confiée
et la vacance de temps de ministère de
votre gouvernement atteste de la
quintessence idéologique de ce projet
politique alors que l'hôpital public se
meurt que le non accès au soins est
généralisé laissant pas moins de 6,7
millions de personnes sans médecin
traitant ce gouvernement ne compte pas
du ministère de la Santé de plein
exercice à nombre alors que le nombre de
travailleurs pauvre et d'emplois
précaire explosent que les réformes
successives et celle à venir menace
l'existence même d'un droit à
l'assurance chômage ce gouvernement ne
compte pas de ministères de travail de
plein exercice alors que la France
traverse une crise du logement d'une
ampleur inédite que le nombre de
personnes sans domicile a doublé en 10
ans que 3000 enfants dorme dans la rue
que 18 % de la population vit dans un
logement insalubre ce gouvernement ne
compte toujours pas de ministre de
logemin alors alors que Lady outremer le
taux de chômage est de à 4 fois plus
élevé que dans l'Hexagone que s' nourrir
il coûte 30 à 42 % plus cher que s'il
trouve les plus grands déserts médicaux
et que le scandale d'État du clordcone
attend la réponse de votre gouvernement
toujours pas de portefeuille dédiés à
ces
territoires alors que notre pays a
besoin de mesures choc pour développer
le transport ferroviaire les transports
en commun à la hauteur des besoins dans
l'urgence de la transition écologique ce
gouvernement ne compte pas de ministre
des transport alors que l'école publique
connaît une crise sans précédent que
près de 10000 enseignants ont disparu
depuis 2017 que la France poursuit sa
chute vertigineuse dans le classement
Pisa pas de ministère de plein exercice
pour éducation nationale pire le jour
même de sa nomination la ministre en
charge de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse des sports des Jeux Olympiques
et parolympiques vter la ségrégation
sociale et le tri social humiliant au
passage les enseignants du
public votre message monsieur le Premier
ministre est clair le règne de
l'héritocratie est désormais assumé et
le triomphe de oligarchie assurée alors
que les guerres bouleversent l'ordre du
monde que l'urgence à l'action pour la
paix nous constatons la mise sous
tutelle de ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui dit avoir pour seul à
tout d'avoir grandi à l'étranger pour
réussir dans sa tâche au combien
difficile et essentielle pour le
rayonnement de la France à
l'international où sont vos propositions
pour réparer notre République abîmée
pour apaiser notre pays déchiré pour
répondre à la souffrance de la majeure
partie du peuple maltraité face au
désespoirs des agriculteurs vous avez
fait le Paris du coup de com sur un
ballot de paille mais vos annonces NT
pas convaincu pas plus que celles
d'aujourd'hui et pour cause aucune
mesure sérieuse pour répondre sur la
durée à la situation catastrophique
qu'ils affrontent rien rien de concret
sur les distorsions de concurrence
nourries par l'importation massive de
produits qui ne respecte pas les normes
sociales ou sanitaires rien sur les
effets du libre échange des traités de
libre échange des assignés seulement un
vague engagement sur le mercosour en
ignorant les autres négociations en
cours rien sur le revenu des agriculteur
les prix planchés et sur la révision en
profondeur du casad des négociations
commerciales je vous le dis on ne DUP pe
pas impunéain ceux qui ne veulent pas
mourir pour pouvoir nourrir et vous ne
duperez pas non plus la majorité des
Françaises et des Français qui ne se
laisseront pas impressionner par une
litanie de mesurettes de court terme
alors qu'ils attendent des réformes de
fond et de progrès social face à une
inflation qui atteint 20 % en cumulé sur
les deux dernières années avec des pics
encore plus important pour les denrises
alimentaires et l'énergie face à la
smigartisation de la France face à la
paupérisation des travailleurs vous ne
proposez rien pour revoir de fon en
comble notre système fiscal et garantir
une meilleure répartition des richesses
et de la valeur rien rien pour réduire
les écarts de revenus rien rien pour
pénaliser la rente financière améliorer
significativement le niveau de vie de
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
bien au contraire vous nous annoncez
poursuivre dans la casse minutieuse de
notre modèle social vous allez laisser
respirer les entreprises avec moins de
normes et étouffer les chômeurs avec
moins de droits et vous avez oublié
comme par hasard de rappeler
l'augmentation des prix d'électricité et
des franchises médical je vous le
demande monsieur le Premier ministre
solennellement renoncer à ces
augmentations face au drame qui se
déroule en Palestine et alors que la
Cour internationale de justice a reconnu
le risque de génocide en cours dans la
bande de Gaza la France comme vous-même
reste des exespément silencieuse et
complaisante à l'égard du gouvernement
israélien
ignorant le rôle que notre pays pourrait
jouer dans cette région pour retrouver
de sa grandeur passée vous
persistez dans votre refus de
reconnaître l'état palestinien à appelé
à un cesser le feu permanent mais vous
précipitez pour suspendre les aides à
l'unra et au réfugiés
palestiniens le fameux deux poids de
mesure est devenu la ligne de conduite
de la diplomatie française enfin vous
nous assurez vouloir être respectueux de
la représentation nationale mais
n'est-ce pas vous monsieur le Premier
ministre qui avait inventé le 4 mai
dernier de concerts avec votre Ministre
tutelle Monsieur le Maire l'obstruction
gouvernementale pour empêcher l'adoption
de notre proposition de loi pour indexer
la DGF sur l'inflation n'est-ce pas vous
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'hypertrophie présidentielle associé à
la servitude de l'exécutif et à votre
pratique de la démocratie parlementaire
ne nous laisse que peu d'espoir Monsieur
le Premier Ministre votre refus de
soumettre votre déclaration de politique
générale au vote de la représentation
nation nation anéanti à lui seul tous
vos efforts déployés à convaincre des
atouts de votre jeunesse pour diriger ce
gouvernement vous en avez la fougue mais
il vous manque le plus essentiel le
courage et le panache pour ce qui
concerne les députés du groupe GDR
communistes et progressistes des
territoires dit d'outrem nous resterons
fidèles aux engagements que nous avons
pris devant les Françaises et les
Français dans le combat entre l'ombre et
la lumière nous nous opposerons au
sabotage méthodique des valeurs qui ont
fait la ur de notre pays et de notre
République indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale nous resterons
fidèles à notre pratique parlementair
travaillant sans relâche ici sur nos
territoires et sur nos territoires pour
être au plus près des besoins et des
préoccupations de Cell ceux qui
souffrent nous déplirons toute notre
énergie pour réparer notre nation parce
que nous sommes pour reprendre des
messeser du côté de l'espérance mais
d'une espérance conquise lucide hors de
toute naïveté oui hors de toute naïveté
c'est qui nous fait dire pour conclure
tcher sortez du corps de notre premier
ministre parce que comme le dit le poète
quand on est réque on est
réac je vous remercie monsieur le
président